hi everyone my name is timon smachtawa
and i'm the lead game designer at
techland welcome to the gamescom edition
of dying to know you can watch the
previous episodes of the show on our
youtube channel they reveal many details
about the game and showcase unique
gameplay videos so if you still haven't
seen them you know what to do
last time we showed you the monsters our
special infected enemies so today let's
talk about how to fight them
and not only them but also the other big
threats you will encounter in the world
of dying light too which are us
humans unfortunately humans tend to be
the most cruel and brutal species out
there especially during an apocalypse
before we talk about fighting let's
start with the basics how do you move
around the city if you watched our
previous episodes you know that a large
portion of the city's population has
changed into monsters roaming the
streets that's why it's extremely
difficult to move around unless you can
run climb brawl swing and jump as the
best option to explore the world of
dying light to is
parkour
let's talk about it with my first guest
katzperkovalchuk senior game programmer
casper you are in a team directly
responsible for creating parkour
movement in dying lights too so what can
you tell the gamescom viewers about it
well we're really excited for the
players to see what we've prepared for
them they will finally feel this amazing
freedom of movement in a city built to
support parkour from the ground up even
the highest building is not an obstacle
anymore but a parkour tool to help you
get higher even those familiar with
dying light 1 will be pleasantly
surprised because we took all that we
learned from parker and dl1 and built
everything from scratch it's a more
challenging way than to simply upgrade
it but it's more rewarding as well okay
but from my perspective
and i think your perspective as well
creating a realistic movement in an fpp
game is very very difficult and we have
spent a lot of time and resources to
make it physical and exciting at the
same time so how do you feel about it
kasper
we really wanted to improve players
perception of their avatar's body and of
what happens to it during parker
the animators had their hands full but
it definitely makes you feel like a real
tracer
which is a person who professionally
does parkour
it's all thanks to dozens or or even
hundreds of new animations it's
especially visible with ropes pipelines
monkey bars etc
with the increased number of animations
players can almost physically feel each
movements while climbing the buildings
it gives them a realistic parkour
experience and is also surprisingly
simple to master even for beginners the
city allows players to traverse it
effectively as soon as they get there
and their mobility increases more as
they learn new skills
there comes a time when players start
noticing synergies between movements and
that's when the real fun begins you
literally feel like flowing through the
environment they also find out that the
city itself helps them with parkouring
and what might have seemed an obstacle
at the beginning becomes an asset once
they learn how to use it
okay but parkour can be more than just
the way to traverse the city in dying
light too it's quite handy in combat too
yes for example i could stun my opponent
with a powerful blow then use elements
of parkour to rebound from him and kick
another one he's also stunned now so i
can rebound from him too by combining
parkour and combat a skillful player can
wreak havoc on both humans and the
infected without even touching the
ground well that sounds amazing so uh
casper thank you for joining us and
thank you for explaining us how the
games parkour system works and i believe
you the same as i just can't wait for
people to see it in action themselves
definitely so thank you once again take
care
so let's talk more about how you can use
parkour not only for traversal but also
for combat and speaking of combat my
next guest is
matt courtois lead technical gameplay
animator
mercy thanks for joining us
i would like to start with something
that was quite difficult for us if you
remember at the very beginning of the
project how to present melee combat in
first person perspective oh i remember
you actually just said creating
satisfying melee combat from a first
person perspective that's a real
challenge that's why we spent many many
weeks iterating it improving it until we
got the right feeling we feel we have
created something special and we're very
excited to discover how how players will
will react to it
so what do you think will excite them
the most
i guess you know we've worked very hard
for our combat to be visceral so we
created many exciting and immersive
elements
such as what we call progressive hit
reactions
so it's basically consecutive hits on
enemies will enhance their reactions
they will react differently based on the
the weapon category you're using based
on the body parts you're targeting so
you can stun them you can trip them over
you can cut off the limbs which might
sound pretty terrible but it's also cool
right and it's and it's also very useful
and and and you know glory
the the direction of your swings also
matters and so does your position
relative to theirs
we we worked also with the professional
stuntmen to record more more special
more more spectacular uh heat reactions
that was mostly for parkour combat
but also generally speaking to highlight
players power and and to convey as much
as much satisfaction as possible and i
think it's safe to say that immersion is
very important in the world of dying
light to its post-apocalypse so it's
very brutal and very demanding so to
survive you really need to step up your
game so i don't know maybe you have some
tips for the players maybe you think
there's something they should focus on
my best advice would be to be creative
in combat so like you just mentioned
with casper in dying light 2 parkour and
combat are very connected they're even
intertwined right allowing players to
combine one with the other very easily
very smoothly so technically you can use
the environment in combat of course as
in kicking an enemy right after a war
run
or
even end you can use the enemy to get
somewhere you like so you would just
vote over them trigger a double jump to
get higher maybe somewhere you had
trouble reaching before but if you want
you can also just land back down trigger
a very powerful attack it's completely
up to you your options are almost
endless that's what we call
creative combat
and to me that would be the best weapon
okay so that's an awesome hint and thank
you for that and thank you for sharing
all of the details
and thank you for joining us
we have used over 3 000 animations of
jumps grips and other parker moves to
create a few dozen skills that can be
mixed and combined so every player can
find her or his own way to survive in
the city in a minute you will see that
in our new gameplay trailer but first
today on
techlandgg.com we have another gift for
you for those who are already exploring
the dying light universe in the first
game we have a unique item the brilliant
hammer a weapon from dying light 2 which
you can use in dying light 1.
go to techland gg and grab it
and if you don't feel like fighting
right now you can get some free posters
wallpapers or even ident special outfit
as you can see it's worth to visit
techlandg.com but
not at this very moment because now it's
time to watch our new gameplay trailer
here it
is sometimes i wonder what this city
looked like before all this
probably like many others
people had their ambitions
plans lives
now it's all gone
the virus started it
but it was the people who made the world
the way it is
this city
villador
they tell me they had a vision
they had hope
but soon one vision broke into many
different ones
instead of fighting together
people stood against each other
war broke out
was it a little bird
lit a broken leg
hope died
now the city is falling
each time we strike down an enemy we
absorb their strength
but i can't let that happen
at least
not yet
[Applause]
i need the secrets this city holds oh
[ __ ] hey
still some rats here
i have to pick a side the bizarre needs
good people
you're doing great so far
[Music]
i have to make a difference
let's check and see
[Applause]
[Music]
they say that great change is a series
of small gestures
[Music]
how about this series
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the trailer presented quite a few new
tools of destruction that you will soon
get to use in dying lights too so now
let's talk with the people that are
actually making them marek mooshau lead
3d weapon artist hi
and shimon styles the producer of the
weapons team hello
the first question maybe to marek is
mark can you explain how we as a team
have approached the process of creating
weapons of dying lights too yes we
wanted the weapons to be credible it's
been a long time since the apocalypse
and everything of value has already been
looted
there aren't any stores to buy a new
weapon so you need to build your
equipment from what you find that's why
we had to design dozens of unique
weapons
practically from scratch and actually
that was our design pillar the modern
dark ages absolutely modern dark ages is
this concept of
fallen civilization that moved back
people
nearly to the middle ages
so there are no laws no rules no
technologies that's why our
weapons we try to create them um in a
most deadly and violent way and working
with that concept where did you get the
inspirations from well
citizens of villadore they could you
only use stuff they found in the world
so we thought we should do exactly the
same we scavenged
so mostly we've been looking for our
inspiration in
stores selling agricultural construction
military tools but also at places like
junkyards actually that's true so right
now we've got nearly 200 of them in-game
and even though some of them may look
very simple we've got also quite the
opposite like i don't know
semi-automatic crossbow i will love this
one and our weapons are very diverse
visually each one has a unique design
and history just by looking at the
weapon you can tell where the maker fund
departs at a military base a museum a
repair exactly
it's exactly like that in the game when
you pick the weapon you instantly
realize if it was cobbled together in a
street or maybe maybe made by factions
where they have access to welding and
steel cutting equipment yeah and don't
forget about the mods because in dying
light to stay human world if you want to
beat your opponent with highly effective
weapon first of all you need to find a
basic version of that weapon and then
slowly build it up that's what we call
modding we've got many types of mods
like defensive ones let's say improving
quality of your handle or offensive ones
like improving the tip or the blade
itself so i don't think that right now
we would have time to talk in details
about that but um in december you all be
able to add an effect to your favorite
weapons such as fire trees electricity
ship on shipment let's stop here let's
leave something for the players to
discover so let's end here and guys
thank you for joining me
before i talk with my last guest i would
like to invite you to participate in our
ugc contest
especially you gamescom viewers we are
waiting for your submissions
and if you are thinking about competing
in the cosplay category you will want to
hear this one let me present to you the
grand jury that will be choosing the
best cosplays of the dying light 2
characters
welcome irina meyer lightning cosplay
narga and aoki and engineite and of
course fingers crossed for you our
community let the best cosplay win
check our website for more details
my last guest will explain how the city
itself affects combat and movement
miho dujak game designer hello and adam
mikhawski senior game programmer hi
demon
gentlemen there's this saying that when
you really want to achieve something the
whole world aligns to help you and
basically that's what is happening in
dying lights to stay human exactly based
on the player choices the world is
literally changing and helping you to
achieve your goals in combat or
exploration
for example the
gameplay will be totally different
depending on which factions you support
the survivors or the peacekeepers okay
but can you give us more detail the
differences between the factions define
how each group can help us for example
the survivors keep to the roofs and
trying to avoid the danger on the ground
for building they use mostly light
materials like wood or scraps and they
can provide you a various amount of
parkour helpers such as amortizers
trampoline or ziplines this can change
the way how we parkour through the city
on the other hand we have peacekeepers
the post-military guys who literally
keep their feet on the ground
and for building they use totally
different materials
heavy metal objects metal
or even explosives and this can give you
a new combat opportunities like car
bombs
heavy traps or even a new type of a
ranged weapon
yeah and what's important is that we
don't need to remain loyal to just one
faction
the city is divided into several zones
and it's in each of them the players can
decide with whom they want to side
so while progressing through the
storyline you're able to shape the world
to future vision and needs okay but we
know already that humans are active
during the day and monsters come out
during the night but let's reveal more
what are the other differences well
monsters attack mostly in groups and
they instinctively take advantage of the
numbers
so to defend yourself you have to keep
your head on the swivel monsters don't
use special tactics but it doesn't mean
they are easy they push forward so you
have to be clever avoid getting cornered
and to win
you have to stay active move a lot and
learn to abuse their unique weaknesses
and explosive traps might call me handy
yeah
okay and what about humans
they use increasingly more complex
behaviors as the game progresses
defeating human enemies and monsters
will become more and more challenging
but unlike monsters people cooperate so
while fighting them we need to closely
observe not only individuals but also
the whole group and of course there are
many more unique subtleties to both
humans and monsters but i think we
should let the players discover them on
their own well okay that's a good idea
but all of that sounds very juicy so
let's end here guys thank you for
joining me
that's almost all for today you learned
a lot about parkour and combat in dying
lights too we showed you that parkour is
not just a tool for exploration but also
an important element of combat you
discovered some of the weapons that you
will soon get to wield and you saw how
choosing a faction may support your
parkour and combat skills
before we end this episode we have one
more special announcement for you dying
light 1 is coming to nintendo switch so
yes it's official now soon you will be
able to play the ultimate open world
zombie game on a new platform and we
know that a lot of you are playing dying
light in june alone the game was played
by close to 2 million gamers
big thanks to our community you're
awesome
dying light one for nintendo switch will
be released in platinum edition this is
the most content packed edition we have
ever released on a single playthrough it
contains over 100 hours of gameplay not
mentioning the time you can spend
exploring the world with your friends in
co-op mode
more details are coming soon
if you are hungry for more and you want
to support us why don't you pre-order
the game to explore it on your own in
just a few months
that's all for today thank you gamescom
and see you in the next episodes of
dying to know
[Music]
oh